a tier 1 org is allegedly making plans
for a marginalized gender owl roster and
while that sounds great in theory there
are concerns that the team will not be
at the skill level as the other teams in
the league and they will face major
backlash as a result this is a bit
tricky but let's talk about it
let me start this video off by saying
this is a very nuanced conversation and
before you comment something at best
stupid you take the time to reflect
think about what we're talking about
maybe do some research talk to a friend
or two just don't be weird in the
comment section all right I am not
afraid to drop kick some gross people so
some of you may be aware about the
initiatives to help bring more
marginalized genders into Esports like
VCT game changers which I was in Berlin
to cover I saw firsthand something a
little Liz would have been inspired by
whether you like it or not or believe it
or not it is hard for marginalized
genders to break into the scene in a
perfect world everyone will be judged
purely based on their skill but we live
in a world of prejudice and so the work
like this needs to be done for
accessibility and to provide spaces like
this for people to literally just play
and grow ah
sorry I'm just uh I'm waiting for the
stupid little internet Gremlins to make
their stupid little comments about like
no one thing
but they never listen so which is why
when it was reported by Liz Richardson
Great Name by the way that according to
sources New York Excelsior or nyxl was
looking to make a team for marginalized
genders to compete in owl on the surface
that seemed exactly like what we were
going for Liz covered in mid-november
nyxl had released their entire owl
roster so they essentially had no
OverWatch team the report stated that
according to sources nyxl was reaching
out to players who had competed in the
recent calling all heroes tournament
that's an OverWatch tournament for
underrepresented genders that's run by
the OverWatch League it was announced on
September 30th of this year and was
described as a joint program of
OverWatch in the OverWatch League
calling all Hero's mission is to build
an inclusive game and competitive
environment for everyone but as
Richardson reported going past the
surface reveals a more complicated
nuanced story according to a source upon
further discussion about how there
aren't enough people to make a tier one
professional roster ready for the owl it
came off as a bad idea that was only set
out for PR and later in the report
Richardson added that quote due to this
lack of available Talent sources stated
that they believe the New York Excelsior
was contacting players of
underrepresented genders below the level
of OverWatch contenders or those with
minimal competitive experience Excelsior
do not want to consider a mixed roster
because this statement isn't wide enough
according to the anonymous source it's
easy to see how a statement not being
wide enough can be seen as an org just
treating this as a PR stunt I do not
think it is any secret that anyone who
is a marginalized gender in Esports
whether it be a content creator a
personality a player receives an
exorbitant amount of hate that can be
traumatic and before you chastise me for
using the word traumatic speaking from
personal experience I have seriously
considered pulling myself completely off
camera because there are days where I've
struggled to get out of my bed because
of the online abuse and harassment I
have received whether it be in the
comment section or my DMs or wherever on
the internet and I'm an absolute nobody
in the scene imagine this 10 or 20 times
more than that if you're a player with
everyone critiquing your skill I I
literally cannot fathom that so let's
summarize according to this report nyxl
wants to create a team of marginalized
genders not for calling all heroes but
for the main owl and as of right now it
seems that there is very little owl
caliber talent to choose from so if his
team is created and they compete in owl
there is a chance they could crash and
burn in front of everyone remember what
I said earlier about my experience think
about that while I read these next
tweets as aramore the social media
manager for the Boston Uprising puts it
when a team crashes and burns it
confirms those awful biases that quote
the community may have already towards
marginalized gender is making it much
harder for them to actually succeed in
the path to Pro and other tournaments
not to mention in ranked misogynists
look for any excuse to confirm their
beliefs and this will give it to them so
to sum everything up there is a concern
that nyxl is not making use of the
calling all heroes initiative a space
made for marginalized genders to hone
their talents instead some are arguing
that my Excel is willing to throw this
team to the Wolves and the regular owl
all for the sake of a statement as
Sapphire said if they earn their spot
through being the best players great I'm
all for having more women in tier one of
those women can't be competitive with
the best and it's simply to check a box
it is going to backfire and only result
in more criticism thrown their way this
is why I am so proud of what we're doing
with hashtag calling all heroes by
creating a stepping stone and an
additional path for women competitors to
improve their skills and hopefully
someday rightfully earn their place in
the tier one League this situation has
Echoes of the League of Legends team ve
victus they were an all-female team who
were kicked from Russia's LCL after
failing to win a single game during the
2019 season according to a source the
players were all diamond ELO for those
of you who don't play league that is a
decent rank for an average player but
nowhere near good enough for pro play
there's lots of accusations of the team
being nothing more than a PR stunt
people feel like the latest situation
with nyxl is similar and could be just
as damaging for women and marginalized
genders in the scene I cannot overstate
how bad of an idea this whole thing is
if it is actually being worked on I mean
if only there was an initiative where
marginalized genders could compete in
OverWatch
oh wait let me be extra clear we are
more than your PR peace your statement
Esports is better with us when you help
us Thrive not toss us into the lake and
expect us to tread water for the entire
time one day this won't even need to be
a conversation but that is not the
reality right now and that's fine so
orgs and devs we need you to be with us
we literally cannot do this without you
and to you my dear viewer thank you
really for watching this video and for
listening to me you are doing the work
that will help make the entire scene
safe and accessible for everyone so
thank you
when I went to historically women's
college and we always used to say it's
not about the absence of men it's with
the presence of us right and I think
that's the really important thing to
remember is this isn't like a man-hating
thing or like we hate men it's really
just for us to as marginalized genders
to grow and to thrive and I think that's
a really important thing to remember I
had that space at my University and I
see the benefit in that and I see the
benefit in spaces like this and I hope
we all can work together to make those
spaces a safe reality